je remercie les employés de dell femmes
georges khoury et me paie le château
logistique unique au samuelsson c'est
qu'une crossing chante le 23 avril
dernier françois legault remercié
plusieurs entreprises du québec pour la
fabrication rapide de blues médicale
parmi ces gens remercie chantal lévesque
entrepreneurs et fondatrice de
l'entreprise chan
bonsoir chantal lévesque une bande son
mais c'est fini parce que vous avez
complètement changé votre chaîne de
production parce que généralement on
vous connaît pour les maillots de bain
pas que ça mais pour les maillots de
bain là vous avez complètement changé
pour faire des blues médicale expliquez
nous ce que vous avez fait en fait comme
tous les entrepreneurs au début de cette
crise je sécurise amis employés
je cale mais la part de tout le monde et
la mienne aussi c'est tellement pas une
démo de change refusé mi plan d'affairé
et une journée j'écoutais notre premier
ministre monsieur legault qui qui
répondait à une question picchi que sur
les chenilles les calculs la finance et
yade il sait pas le temps de compter
s'il t'a d'âge et puis je me suis dit
c'est vrai que c'est le temps d'agir
qu'est-ce que je peux faire à très court
terme pour arrêter de toute façon de
planifier ski difficile de planifier
foule inconnu on le sait pas donc là je
suis parti carrément dans mon usine qui
était tristement vide et avec une
collègue
on a développé on a travaillé sur la
blouse et sur le masque de protection
puis on a rapidement été capable de
trouver ce que le réseau de la santé
demande et puis c'est parti comme ça au
bout de deux jours c'était un ami sur
notre site web et puis le sait la folie
c'est la folie c'est à dire que la
demande est forte la demande est forte
on est beaucoup de difficultés a prévu à
voir les matières premières ça a été
difficile aussi de
de faire revenir les employés les
employés avaient préparé on a mis en
place tout ce qu'il fallait mettre en
place mais c'est correct que ça se fasse
en douceur parce que même pour nous qui
pour les gestionnaires et on a une
responsabilité énorme
il faut vraiment protéger nos employés
il faut les superviser s'assurer qu'ils
respectent les normes donc on a commencé
doucement
là ça fait trois semaines je vous dirais
qu'au bout de trois semaines on n'a pas
à leur dire parce que tout change en
oeuvre leurs masques à partir du moment
où il touche le match vous recommencez
tout le processus dont celle ci c'est
pas évident mais au bout de trois
semaines ça fonctionne parce que tu nous
faut se réinventer dans le fort il faut
non seulement réinventer son entreprise
que vous faites avec ces produits là
mais vous devez repenser les liens les
relations de travail
est-ce que vous avez rappelé tout le
monde on a tenté de rappeler tout le
monde dans la production sur les 85
employés aujourd'hui on est et on avait
52 personnes qui travaillaient à laval
et évidemment il y en a qui ont des
enfants y en option là les parents sont
agriculteurs ça fait partie de notre
nouvelle réalité
il faut qu'on puisse accepter qu'on a
des employés ou plus âgés ou prix avec
des situations personnelles
particulières mais je vous dirais que la
part de mort encore le gros du problème
mais plus les employés à entendre parler
leurs collègues de la sécurité et
surtout du fait qu' on travaille
vraiment pour une cause
on en a livré des plots de protection
une chute québec la semaine prochaine
c'est important que la cause de notre
graphe la cause de très noble sa cellule
de joucou oui ça les touche beaucoup
c'est sûr que c'est fou c'est
complètement fou travailler dans des
conditions comme ceci puis je pense que
ça va dire ça va être ça va être ça pour
longtemps oui et là ça va de soi pour
longtemps mais en même temps le
gouvernement du secteur manufacturier on
reprend le 11 mai est-ce que vous tout à
coup c'est une date importante pour vous
elle ne le fait que moi je crois pas à
reprendre la production avec mon secteur
d'activité très très court terme
la réouverture de mes boutiques je
savais en douceur encore lol on sait que
les employés ont trait pas je pense que
ça va être ça va se faire en douceur
on se repose ouvert complètement nous
dans les dates aux physiquement entrepôt
capable mais ils n'en sont pas capables
c'est une bénédiction jusqu'à un certain
point pour vous d'avoir pu transformer
votre ligne de production qu'elle m'a
tellement parce que on aurait pu porter
au travail c'est c'est tellement
difficile pour notre secteur d'activité
nous en plus ça s'est passé juste avant
l'été les voyages après ça pour
l'automne c'était la pire jamais de bon
moment mais pour nous c'était le pire
moment au niveau du cash flow c'est
c'est hyper difficile qui de garder nous
employer à la maison télétravail dans
notre site d'entreprise c'est pas
vraiment mon malgré qu'on a appris on a
beaucoup appris je pense que ça c'est
tout les entrepreneurs à prendre mais je
serai pas on ferme un belge et moi j'ai
eu parle c'est la première fois que j'ai
aussi par série no imagé mais mais en
même temps on nous ont rapidement
sécurisé je pense que nos gouvernements
ont fait une super job là dessus ils
nous ont apporté des solutions d des
façons de oui on va s'endetter une
personne m 60 et et puis ça fait pas
mais quand on est on a une entreprise on
ne peut jamais prévoir le c'est ce qu'il
faut qu'on fasse et vous avez demandé le
gouvernement
oui la gg j'ai demandé de l'aide pour
pour supporter le passage l'appui si ça
on va passer on travaille bien
bonne chance mais mme chantal lévesque
et merci d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
salutations vos employés également qui
vit cette situation particulière
à la prochaine